los israelíes volvieron desde este
domingo a las terrazas a disfrutar de un
buen café acariciando el retorno de su
país a una cierta normalidad
la reapertura de restaurantes y
cafeterías como ésta fue autorizada por
el gobierno luego de que cerca del 53%
de los habitantes recibiera al menos la
primera dosis de la vacuna contra el cob
y 19
el primer ministro benjamin netanyahu
fue de los primeros en visitar uno de
los establecimientos que volvieron a
entrar en funcionamiento en jerusalén
los restaurantes están volviendo a la
vida todavía tenemos que mirar ya sabes
cuidarnos tenemos que usar mascarillas
para mantener las distancias requeridas
pero estamos saliendo de esto
pero aunque muchos celebran la des
escalada de las restricciones otros
dudan sobre las cifras estoy muy
emocionado de que las cosas vuelvan a la
normalidad pero veamos cómo funciona
como no estoy seguro de todas las
vacunas
y habrá ciudadanos clase a y clase b el
que fue vacunado y el que no así que
espero que las cosas mejoren pronto
esta reapertura se suma a las medidas
aplicadas desde hace varias semanas como
el funcionamiento de los centros de ocio
y los gimnasios
las autoridades sanitarias advirtieron
que un creciente rebrote podría
desencadenar otro cierre lo cual
intentan evitar de cara a las elecciones
del 23 de marzo en las que netanyahu
tras meses de protestas en su contra
buscará la victoria